the question today is not
why did we invade afghanistan the
question is
why are we still in afghanistan one
decade later
why are we spending 135
billion dollars
why have we got 130 000 troops on the
ground
why were more people killed
last month
than in any preceding month of this
conflict
how has this happened
the last
20 years
has been the age of intervention
and afghanistan is simply one act in a
five-act tragedy
we came out at the end of the cold war
in despair
we faced rwanda
we faced bosnia
and then we rediscovered our confidence
in the third act
we went into bosnia and kosovo and we
seemed to succeed
in the fourth act with our hubris our
overconfidence developing
we invaded iraq and afghanistan
and in the fifth act
we plunged into a humiliating mess
so the question is what are we doing why
are we still stuck in afghanistan and
the answer of course
that we keep being given
is as follows
we're told that we went into afghanistan
because of 9 11
and that we remain there because the
taliban poses an existential threat to
global security in the words of
president obama
if the taliban take over again
they will invite back al qaeda who will
try to kill as many of our people
as they possibly can
the story that we're told is that there
was a light footprint initially in other
words that we ended up in a situation
where we didn't have enough troops we
didn't have enough resources that
afghans were frustrated they felt there
wasn't enough progress in economic
development and security
and therefore the taliban came back
that we responded in 2005 and 2006 with
troop deployments
but we still didn't put enough troops on
the ground
and that it wasn't until 2009
when president obama signed off on a
surge
that we finally had
in the words of secretary clinton
the strategy the leadership and the
resources so that as the president now
reassures us
we are on track
to achieve our goals
all of this is wrong
every one of those statements is wrong
afghanistan does not pose an existential
threat to global security
it is extremely unlikely the taliban
would ever be able to take over the
country
extremely unlikely they'd be able to
seize kabul they simply don't have a
conventional military option and even if
they were able to do so even if i'm
wrong
it's extremely unlikely the taliban
would invite back al qaeda from the
taliban's point of view
that was their number one mistake last
time if they hadn't invited back al
qaeda they would still be in power today
and even if i'm wrong about those two
things even if they were able to take
back the country even if they were to
invite back al qaeda
it's extremely unlikely that al qaeda
would significantly enhance its ability
to harm the united states or harm europe
because this isn't the 1990s anymore if
the
al qaeda base was to be established near
ghazni
we would hit them very hard and it would
be very very difficult for the taliban
to protect them
furthermore
it's simply not true that what went
wrong in afghanistan is the light
footprint
in my experience in fact the light
footprint was extremely helpful
and these troops that we brought in
this great picture david beckham there
on the submachine gun
made the situation worse not better
when i walked across afghanistan in the
winter of 2001 2002
what i saw was scenes like this
a girl if you're lucky in the corner of
a dark room
lucky to be able to look at the quran
but in those early days when we're told
we didn't have enough troops and enough
resources we made a lot of progress in
afghanistan within a few months there
were two and a half million more girls
in school
in sangi's art where i was sick in 2002
the nearest health clinic was within
three days walk
today there are 14 health clinics in
that area alone
there was amazing improvements we went
from almost no afghans having mobile
telephones during the taliban to a
situation where almost overnight three
million afghans had mobile telephones
and we had progress in the free media we
had progress in elections all of this
with the so-called light footprint
but when we began to bring more money
when we began to invest more resources
things got worse not better how well
firstly if you put 125 billion dollars a
year into a country like afghanistan
where the entire revenue of the afghan
state is one billion dollars a year
you drown everything
it's not simply corruption and waste
that you create
you essentially replace the priorities
of the afghan government the elected
afghan government
with the micromanaging tendencies of
foreigners on short tours
with their own priorities and the same
is true with the troops
when i walked across afghanistan i
stayed with people like this this is
commandant
hajimax and khan kamenji
kamadam walimhaji mohsenhan kamenji was
a great host he was very generous like
many of the afghans i stayed with but he
was also considerably more conservative
considerably more anti-foreign
considerably more islamist than we like
to acknowledge
this man for example muller mustafa
tried to shoot me
the reason i'm looking a little bit
perplexed in this photograph is i was
somewhat frightened and i was too afraid
on this occasion to ask him having run
for an hour through the desert and
taking refuge in this house
why he had turned up and wanted to have
his photograph taken with me
but 18 months later i asked him why he
had tried to shoot me
and muhammad who is the man of the pen
and paper explained that the man sitting
immediately to the left as you look at
the photograph nadia shah had bet him
that he couldn't hit me
now this is not to say afghanistan is a
place full of people like mueller
mustafa it's not it's a wonderful place
full of incredible energy and
intelligence
but it is a place where
the putting in of the troops has
increased the violence rather than
decreased it
2005 anthony fitzherbert an agricultural
engineer could travel through helmand
could stay in nadia sangeen and garesh
which are now the names of villages
where fighting is taking place today he
could never do that
so the idea that we deployed the troops
to respond to the taliban insurgency is
mistaken
rather than preceding the insurgency the
taliban
followed the troop deployment
and as far as i'm concerned the troop
deployment caused their return
now is this a new idea no
there have been any number of people
saying this over the last seven years i
ran a center at harvard from 2008 to
and there were people like michael
semple there who speak afghan languages
fluently who've traveled to almost every
district in the country andrew wilder
for example
born
on the pakistan-iranian border
served his whole life in pakistan and
afghanistan
paul fishstein who began working there
in 1978 worked for save the children
ran the afghan research and evaluation
unit
these are people who were able to say
consistently
that the increase in development aid was
making afghanistan less secure not more
secure that the counter-insurgency
strategy was not working and would not
work
and yet
nobody listened to them instead
there was a litany of astonishing
optimism
beginning in 2004 every general came in
saying
i've inherited a dismal situation but
finally i have the right resources and
the correct strategy which will deliver
in general bano's word in 2004
the decisive year
well guess what it didn't
but it wasn't sufficient to prevent
general abuse aid saying that he had the
strategy and the resources to deliver in
the decisive year of general david
richards to come in in 2006 and say he
had the strategy and the resources to
deliver the crunchier or in 2007 the
norwegian deputy foreign minister espen
ida to say that that would deliver the
decisive year or in 2008 major general
shampoo to come in and say he would
deliver the decisive year or in 2009 my
great friend general sani mcchrystal who
said that he was knee-deep in the
decisive year or in 2010 the uk foreign
secretary david miliband who said that
at last we would deliver the decisive
year and you'll be delighted to hear in
2011 today that guido vestavelle the
german foreign minister assures us that
we are in the decisive year now
how how
do we allow any of this to happen
well the answer of course is if you
spend 125 billion 130 billion dollars a
year in a country you co-opt almost
everybody
even the aid agencies who begin to
receive an enormous amount of money from
the us and the european governments to
build schools and clinics are somewhat
disinclined to challenge the idea that
afghanistan is an existential threat to
global security they're worried in other
words that if anybody believed that it
wasn't such a threat
oxfam save the children wouldn't get the
money to build their hospitals and
schools
it's also very difficult to confront a
general with medals on his chest
it's very difficult for a politician
because you're afraid that many lives
have been lost in vain you feel deep
deep guilt you exaggerate your fears
and you're terrified about the
humiliation of defeat
what is the solution to this
well the solution to this is we need to
find a way that people like michael
semple or those other people who are
telling the truth
who know the country who've spent 30
years on the ground and most importantly
of all
the missing component of this
afghans themselves
who understand what is going on
we need to somehow get their message to
the policy makers
and this is very difficult to do
because of our structures the first
thing we need to change is the
structures of our government
very very sadly our foreign services the
united nation the military
in these countries have very little idea
what's going on the average british
soldier is on a tour of only six months
italian soldiers on tours of four months
the american military on tours of 12
months diplomats are locked in embassy
compounds when they go out they travel
in these curious armored vehicles with
these somewhat threatening security
teams who recce 24 hours in advance who
say you can only stay on the ground for
an hour in the british embassy in
afghanistan in 2008
an embassy of 350 people there were only
three people who could speak diary the
main language of afghanistan at a decent
level and there was not a single push to
speaker in the afghan section in london
responsible for governing afghan policy
on the ground
i was told last year that there was not
a single staff member of the foreign
office in that section who had ever
served on a posting in afghanistan
so we need to change that institutional
culture and i can make the same points
about the united states and the united
nations
secondly we need to aim off of the
optimism of the generals we need to make
sure that we're a little bit suspicious
that we understand that optimism is in
the dna of the military that we don't
respond to it with quite as much
alacrity
and thirdly we need to have some
humility we need to begin from the
position
that our knowledge
our power
our legitimacy is limited
this doesn't mean
that intervention around the world is a
disaster it isn't
bosnia and kosovo
were signal successes
great successes
today when you go to bosnia it is almost
impossible to believe
that what we saw in the early 1990s
happened it's almost impossible to
believe the progress we've made since
refugee return which the united nations
high commission for refugees thought
would be extremely unlikely
has largely happened a million
properties have been returned
borders between the bosniak territory
and the bosnian serb territory have come
down
the national army has shrunk the crime
rates in bosnia today are lower than
they are in sweden
right
this has been done by an incredible
principled effort by the international
community
and of course above all by bosnians
themselves
but you need to look at context and this
is what we've lost in afghanistan and
iraq you need to understand that in
those places what really mattered
was firstly the role of tuchman and
milosevic in coming to the agreement and
then the fact that those men went
that the regional situation improved
that the european union could offer
bosnia something extraordinary the
chance to be part of a new thing a new
club a chance to join something bigger
and finally we need to understand that
in bosnia and kosovo a lot of the secret
of what we did
a lot of the secret of our success
was our humility was the tentative
nature of our engagement we criticized
people a lot in bosnia for being quite
slow to take on war criminals we
criticized them for being quite slow to
return refugees but that slowness that
caution the fact that president clinton
initially said that american troops
would only be deployed for a year turned
out to be a strength and it helped us to
put our priorities right
one of the saddest things about our
involvement in afghanistan
is that we've got our priorities out of
sync we're not matching our resources to
our priorities because if what we're
interested in is terrorism pakistan is
far more important than afghanistan if
what we're interested in is regional
stability egypt is far more important if
what we're worried about is poverty and
development sub-saharan africa is far
more important
this doesn't mean afghanistan doesn't
matter but that it's one of 40 countries
in the world with which we need to
engage
so if i can finish with a metaphor
for intervention
what we need to think of
is something like
mountain rescue
why mountain rescue
because when people talk about
intervention they imagine there's some
scientific theory the rand corporation
goes around counting 43 previous
insurgencies producing mathematical
formula saying you need one trained
counterinsurgent for every 20 members of
the population
this is the wrong way of looking at it
you need to look at it in the way that
you look at mountain rescue when you're
doing mountain rescue
you don't take a doctorate in mountain
rescue
you look for somebody who knows the
terrain
it's about context
you understand that you can prepare but
the amount of preparation you can do is
limited you can take some water you can
have a map
you can have a pack but what really
matters
is two kinds of problems
problems that occur on the mountain
which you couldn't anticipate
such as for example ice on a slope but
which you can get round
and problems which you couldn't
anticipate and which you can't get round
like a sudden blizzard or an avalanche
or a change of the weather
and the key to this is a guide who has
been on that mountain
in every temperature at every period
a guy who above all knows when to turn
back who doesn't press on relentlessly
when conditions turn against them what
we look for
in firemen in climbers and policemen and
what we should look for in intervention
is intelligent risk takers not people
who plunge blind off a cliff
not people who jump into a burning room
but who weigh their risks weigh their
responsibilities because the worst thing
we have done in afghanistan is this idea
that failure is not an option
it makes failure
invisible
inconceivable and inevitable and if we
can resist
this crazy slogan we shall discover in
egypt in syria in libya and anywhere
else we go in the world
that if we can often do much less than
we pretend
we can do much more than we fear
thank you very much
thank you
thank you thank you
rory you mentioned libby at the end uh i
just briefly what's what's your take on
on the current events there and the
intervention
okay i think libya poses the classic
problem
the problem in libya is that we are
always pushing for the black or white we
imagine there are only two choices
either full engagement and troop
deployment or total isolation
and we are always being tempted up to
our neck we put our toes in and we go in
up to our neck what we should have done
in libya is we should have stuck to the
un resolution we should have limited
ourselves very very strictly to the
protection of the civilian population in
benghazi we could have done that we set
up a no-fly zone within 48 hours because
qadhafi had no planes within 48 hours
instead of which we have allowed
ourselves to be tempted towards regime
change in doing so we've destroyed our
credibility with the security council
which means
it's very difficult to get a resolution
on syria and we're setting ourselves up
again for failure once more humility
limits honesty
realistic expectations and we could have
achieved something to be proud of
thank you thank you very much